what is this
happy holidays dwight but do not open it
till christmas
you're so pathetic how long did this
take you three hours five minutes
actually
i am a black belt in gift wrapping yeah
no such thing they don't give out black
belts for things that are stupid
well i hope it was worth it because i'm
gonna take it apart in about five
minutes
i think it'll take you a little bit
longer than that really if i can skin a
mule deer in less than 10 minutes
i ought to be able to cut my
it's happening again rosa rosa hitchcock
fell asleep in the break room i pranked
him i tied his shoelaces together
38 years old dude i know and yet my
pranks still stay so fresh it's
incredible gotta untie his shoes before
he gets hurt
seriously seriously ugh fine but what's
the worst thing that could happen
he's being shrank on the cabs pow
morning dwight
who are you who am i
i'm jim we've been working together for
12 years
we're joked white you're not jim jim's
not asian
you seriously never noticed hey hats off
to you for not seeing race
all right then jim uh why don't you tell
me about that
sale that you made yesterday uh
wellington systems
sold them 10 cases of 24-pound letter
stock or
were you talking about creek or murphy
because i didn't close that one yet but
i'm hoping
i've got a voicemail from paul krieger
waiting for me
please enter your password
you have one new message how did you no
no
no no that is sensitive information only
for employees not outsiders dwight cut
it out i'm trying to work
you don't work here you're not jim jim i
got us that dinner reservation greek
goes 7 30. oh great can't wait
jim's at the dentist this morning and
steve is an actor friend of ours
i don't know who you are but you are not
jim
this is jim
home oh dude uh how did
hey charles can we talk in the briefing
room for a second there's a question i
got to ask you hmm
it's happening jake is going to pop the
question
he's going to ask me to be his bm no bm
best man is a common abbreviation
no one but you has ever used it i am so
relieved
i thought maybe he was going to ask one
of amy's brothers or who
sarge hey man come on charles
okay so i know this is a lot to ask
no it's not i want to do it you want to
cover my shift this weekend so i can go
to the white plains mall and meet daryl
strawberry at the opening of a cell
phone store
yes that's exactly what i was hoping
you'd ask great
thanks you sure it's okay
i'm very happy about it that'll be fun
it'll be fun uh look at my smile
i have to go now
oh my god jake what do you say bud
will you be my bm yes yes a million
times yes
in your face terry what i'm holding a
sparkler for you i helped organize a lot
of this oh you can stick that sparkle up
your butt
i'm the best man
hello this is dwight schrute from the
dunder mifflin paper company well that's
great because i need paper
excellent then you are in luck because
we are having a limited time offer only
on
everything wow this is my lucky day what
is your name sir
i am bill buttlicker really that's your
real name
how dare you my family built this
country by the way
are you respectful dwight please oh yes
michael could you hold on one second
that's my other line
what no but i hello yeah
no i'm just on the phone with this
stupid salesman he's so dumb
probably just going to keep him on the
line forever and not buy anything
okay it's up to you to change his mind
sorry that was a
family emergency oh no what's wrong you
know what that's private
boundaries dwight come on i'm sorry mr
butt licker as i was saying
we're having a limited a little bit
louder i'm hard of hearing he's hard if
he's an old man
okay as i was saying right now we are
going to talk louder
okay our prices have never been low you
have to talk louder never been lower
louder son but liquor our prices have
never been lowered
that is totally inappropriate you never
yell at the client
now you listen to me sir here we go the
three words i would describe you as
is aggressive yes hostile and definitely
difficult
please mr buy my rate right give me the
please give me a chance give me the
phone mr butler give me the phone i have
to put you on with my boss well i should
hope so
who is this hello this is michael scott
regional manager
well this is william m buttlicker hello
mr buttlicker how may we help you
michael i like the sound of your voice
you know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna buy
one million dollars worth of paper
products today
see how it's done thank you very much
sir i don't think you'll regret it
you are the master there is one
condition michael yes you have to fire
the salesman that treated me so terribly
don't do it michael it's a
million-dollar sale
i'm so glad we could finally do this i
know kylie says you're always stuck at
the pricing
yeah speaking of this is work sorry
what's up peralta captain called he
needs everybody back there's a lead on
the nightingale strangler
we're looking for a white male 510
medium build brown hair
small scar on his right cheek okay
his mo is he finds lonely women with no
friends
poisons their food and then guts them in
his van it's pretty gnarly
last seen wearing a salmon shirt gray
blazer
and witnesses have said he has trouble
fitting lettuce in his mouth
okay where are you apparently has the
world's smallest penis and doesn't know
how to use it
hi there i'm jake peralta amy's boss
that's not true what are you doing here
i am here on a date who is now leaving
worth it have a great night your boss
seems really nice he's not my boss
yes i am
it's kind of blurry
that's better
question what kind of bear is best
that's a ridiculous question false black
bear
well that's debatable there are
basically two schools of thought fact
bears eat beets bears
beets battlestar galactica bears do not
what is going on what are you doing last
week i was in a drug store and i saw
these
glasses uh four dollars and it only cost
me seven dollars to recreate the rest of
the ensemble and that's a grand total of
eleven dollars you know what imitation
is the most sincere form of flattery
so i thank you identity theft is not a
joke jim
millions of families suffer every year
michael oh that's funny michael
i have a great idea for a prank before
holt comes in i'm gonna put ink on the
podium where he puts his hands i don't
think he'll fall for that i did
how i haven't even opened this yet i
guess it's unrelated captain holt hates
pranks this is gonna backfire man ugh
fine i'll tone it down i'll move his
podium a foot to the left what he'll be
so angry okay five inches
five three three one one all right i'll
move it a half inch
fine it's your funeral oh my god
worst prank ever so stupid holt's not
even gonna notice
good morning
you guys at the podium
you're crazy how did you pull this off
okay so dwight in your own words
someone replaced all my pens and pencils
with crayons i suspect jim halpert
everyone has called me dwayne all day i
think jim halpert paid them to
yes five bucks each and it was totally
worth it
this morning i found a bloody glove in
my desk drawer and jim halpert tried to
convince me i committed murder
i think he may be the real murderer jim
halpert said there was an abandoned
infant in the woman's room when i went
to save the child i saw meredith on the
can
this morning i knocked myself in the
head with the phone
that actually took a while i had to put
uh more and more nickels into his
handset
until he got used to the weight and then
i just took them all out
every time i typed my name it said
diapers
just a simple macro you know
these actually don't sound that funny
one after another but he does
deserve it though by the end of the day
my desk was about two feet closer to the
copier
yeah i just moved it an inch every time
i went to the bathroom
and that's how i spent my entire day
that day
you